you
hi everyone it's Jerry this is Game
three from the 2014 World Chess
Championship match between Magnus
Carlsen and Vishy Anand going into this
round Carlson has one and a half points
and Nan has half a point in this game
Anand has the white pieces he opened
with d4 Carlsen replying Knight f6 c4 e6
welcoming the nimzo-indian defense
should Knight c3 be played but instead
it was Knight f3 and now d5 Queens
gambit declined following up Knight c3
Bishop e7 and Bishop to have for the
classical variation black castles white
with this move by the way has their
Bishop ideally placed outside of their
punching as a follow-up Knight on B to
d7 and c5 with this move white grabbed
some Queen side space and this pawn can
be reinforced if challenged and we will
see a challenge soon enough one other
detail is that this Bishop here keep in
mind is the bad bishop on the black side
these next handful of moves will not
only look to try and break down the
structure but permit black to exchange
their light square bishop for white's
good bishop but first we have c6 Bishop
d3 b6 White's there to reinforce the c5
pawn black looks to break down this
structure further and renews this
possibility
I will not renews the possibility makes
way for Bishop a6 right now a3 is there
to defend b4 which means
c5 will live and white will maintain
this Queen side space advantage this
particular game right here reminded me
of one that I covered recently between
Lyra and ding and Levon Aronian in that
game we have the bishop still inside of
the pawn chain but still there were
these similar ideas one that will show
up in the game at least regarding pawn
breaks
as the follow-up it was Bishop to a6 the
light-square bishop tsar off and now
this sharp reply b5 it's a very
theoretical line here rook is hit c6 is
hit very limited replies C takes B is
forced and now c6 this pawn is now a
runner passed pawn and comes with tempo
against the knight but black keeps a
cool head queen c8 is there preparing to
meet pawn takes Knight with Queen takes
Knight
instead it's c7 this pond will live
watched over very nicely with the bishop
on f4 and as a follow up we have B for
the night is now hit a lot of tension
here another fork in the position Knight
b5 it's important not to take here as
otherwise you're inviting a piece into
your territory and the night is now
pinned this is not a good idea for white
instead what's best is to plant the
night right in to b5 so this is yet
another defender of the invaluable past
C pawn that is just a moment away from
promoting next we have a for initially I
was thinking this was played in order to
allow rook to a5 and while that's true
what's maybe most important is to make
sure white is not allowed to play a 4
just making a passing move just to note
this a for advance now this Knight is
not going anywhere
and he's ideally placed to watch over c7
this is just too good too great of a
coordination on the white side here to
allow white to plant their eponymous
acure this Knight which is in the black
position so this is maybe an additional
reason in other words behind a 4 not
only to play rook a5 but to also stop
white from playing a5 themselves so
after a 4 it was rook c1 one thing white
would like to do here is throw a minor
piece into this Square Knight d6 however
played at this moment with loud this
pandu simply be captured
bishop here Bishop takes Knight takes
he's yet again captured so the C pawn in
other words need some more support
before a minor piece is of any threat to
get to that d6 post so that's what
prompts the next move rook c1 now this
is back on and this is where the main
attention will be focused for these next
few moves black needs to do something
about one of these white minor pieces
getting into d6 and he does just that
with Knight e4 two pieces there to
defend white cannot jump in there just
yet but the white is persistent with the
Knight g5 trying to lure the piece away
from d6 in the game we saw Knight D to
f6 keep in mind if Bishop takes Knight
there can follow up Bishop takes Bishop
and if this Knight is grabbing here well
this is going to be game over 96 is
absolutely deadly Queen is hit and if
she moves white pushes through this is
game over for black in other words you
wouldn't be able to capture twice on
this g5 square what is tried is Knight D
to f6 reinforcing the knight if he's
captured black has the option of
recapturing with the knight and that's
what we see in the game Knight takes
Knight and the knight is the one who now
recaptures and this is where there is
maybe a slip in this game you'll notice
the clock situation by the way at this
moment here is level however on this
move 17 we did have to wait some time
before Carlsen made his play before he
made his 17th move a minute 8 remaining
after this next move how much time was
spent a good 35 let's call it a good 30
minutes on that move right there Knight
D to f6 as the follow-up Knight takes
Knight and Black was very quick to
recapture with the Knight apparently
trusting his calculations what he had
worked out at this moment right here
when he played 90 to f6
this next move did come very quick after
Knight takes Knight he did recapture
with the knight on e4 and I believe that
this was a a mistake or an inaccuracy
that leads to white gaining a little bit
more of an advantage down the line what
was maybe better at this point is to
capture what the pun and what this is
allowing for is the knight to make use
of the d6 square may seem a bit scary of
course to now allow one of these minor
pieces to get into d6 but with this
knight being able to play to d5 this
does seem to be still a relatively equal
position let's have a look at one of the
lines let's jump right in there with one
of the most direct moves after this
what-if scenario D takes e4 what if now
Knight d6 how to cope with that well
there can follow Bishop takes Knight
Bishop has to recapture and now not
moving the rook moving the rook would
allow Bishop takes pawn and White is the
one who stands very well here however a
better play is to give up the rook and
play this move B 3 and on Bishop takes
rook King takes is otherwise he pushes
through and now this Knight since we had
D take see this Knight will be very
nicely anchored on that d5 post where he
had exerts pressure on c7 he watches
over the b4 square which is certainly
important as this allows for potential B
for pawn break and before you know it
there can be now two connected passed
pawns close to striking close to
promoting so this did not happen but was
maybe a better continuation here to not
take with the knight but rather take
with the pun which would free up which
would vacate that d5 square nice post
or a black night okay in the game it was
Knight takes Knight black is there
directly to watch over d6 and white is
there twice can't go there just yet
white still tries to do something about
that d6 square by giving the knight a
kick
efore is not a stable square and black
is now very limited does not have very
many choices the knight is hit if he
goes here he's going to be taken out and
white stands better in this position and
the other choice well that was the move
played in the game rook a five white
grabs the knight black gets the knight
right back Queen takes a for grabs a pun
and hits the rook rook a5 not very many
choices Queen c6 sinking deeper into the
white position this pawn is passed and
with B takes a black also has a passed
pawn and you'll notice the bishops how
they are similar both are watching over
a passed pawn but who's passed pawn is
more significant this guy is just one
step away during the livestream I was
pointing out that this is a very
inconvenienced Queen if there's one
piece you do not want to have as a block
hater for a passed pawn it's a queen she
likely will want to be doing more useful
things than stopping upon from advancing
but this is the situation black finds
themselves in right now the Queen can't
move the pawn is very well supported
this one also is supported but again the
black queen is tied down the white queen
is not tied down as a follow up eat XD
rook takes D Queen takes b6 Queen d7
black looks to have a little role
reversal here the rook wants to be the
one who blockades on c8 so that the
Queen is a little bit more freed up
light finally castles on this move 25
very late stage in the game to be
castling but there were other more
pressing issues up
until that point only again it moved 25
did we have castles another idea was to
play Queen a6 I really I really like
this move during the livestream I was
pointing this out this idea to try and
push through immediately with c8 after
it moved like rook c8 there can follow
rook b1 looking at these ideas RIPTA
being black at this point would have to
give up the exchange grabbing on c7 this
would be too much if this was allowed
the rook to b8 there's not a good way to
defend the c8 square for a second time
black would have to take on c7 there can
follow rook b8 Bishop to d8 and Bishop
takes on c7 White would be up the
exchange in this position rook c8 as a
follow up white is the better side white
is the winning side we didn't have that
castles is what was on rook c8 rook c6
this is interfering with any
coordination the Queen and rook may have
on the b5 square there's no way to let's
say give the Queen a kick now rook c6
interferes with that idea and keep in
mind there's also maybe an idea of at
some point playing the rook to be 6 + b8
or even with this last move now we have
ideas of the rook coming in to b1 and
then getting into that b8 square this is
a very nice useful move to c6 and now
this next one move 26 not a move you're
really half want to make but is because
it's a very weakening week ending these
four squares very lashing out type of
move very committal move it is there
however to create a flight square in
such an open position like this you
really want to try and get the move back
if possible and do so with tempo g5 has
this flight square in mind and it throws
a punch at the bishop Anand was thinking
on Carlson's time most likely here this
g5 move took about
ten minutes and anons reply came right
back in less than a minute
Bishop g3 I was thinking Bishop e5 but
you may be in the position as white
allowing black to take this bishop and
take on c7 if you don't have enough
coverage for it so while this may seem
more aggressive to meet this g5 move
with moving forward and still taking
away that flight square again you run
into maybe these types of sacrifices at
some point instead it was the much more
calm and fine move good move bishop g3
this bishop will maintain his control
over the c7 pound black will not find it
as easy to remove defenders of this guy
on c7 which remains blacks number one
responsibility you have to stop this
pawn from moving and try and track him
down but it's very difficult to see how
black will manage that as a follow up it
was Bishop to b4 and then rook to a1
notice you cannot take here the Queen
does have the responsibility of watching
over the rook on c6 so Queen Queen takes
bishop we would have Queen takes rook in
the game it was rook to a1 one of the
ideas behind this Bishop before move is
to play into d2 where it puts pressure
on an unprotected pun and if he falls
well he could potentially fall with
Czech and if he's gone there goes d4
soon thereafter so black after blacks
Bishop to b4 move white replies with
rook a one convenient way to deal with
Bishop d2 if Bishop d2 is played now
rook a3 wins that wins blacks only asset
they're past a pawn and conveniently
defends the pawn on III so this rook a1
move stops Bishop d2 and as a follow up
we have Bishop to a5 what's maybe better
here on the black side is -
unfortunately sit
wait not commit this bishop in either
direction to not move the bishop in
other words to just keep him on before
but they're kind of nothing moves the
computer suggestion for the black side
is unfortunately moves like King g7 h6
mm-hmm
excuse me age six h5 type of moves if we
have a look at this h5 advance there can
follow h3 h5 by the way would be aimed
at trying to kick this bishop off of
this diagonal but he's not going
anywhere after a move like h5 there can
be h3 and on h4 just drop the bishop
back and where do you make further
progress I mean if you make it just to
kind of a passing move King age 7 or
maybe playing rook here white is the one
who will be able to make progress in
fact one thing Y can be doing here the
only thing that was keeping white from
playing looked to see one earlier I
should have mentioned that at this point
right here instead of rook to a1 white
would really like to play the move rook
c1 to double rooks bring the Queen over
to a6 the rook over to b6 and then we
get this rook into b8 but playing the
rook to see one right here is running
into this fork however with rook a1 in
and these few moves inserted on the
Kings side and this semi passing move
King a7 again King h7 there really
wouldn't be much that black can do here
rook a to is strong this is now getting
ready to play rook c2 there would be no
bishop to detail and white is ready to
transfer his attention to putting
pressure on the c8 square with moves
like Queen a6 rook B 6 and then rook to
b8 this is a very strong post for a
major piece connected very well with the
bishop here on this diagonal here
indirectly watching over the b8 square
okay well in the game we did not have
these types of moves h6 h5 King g7
they're kind of nothing moves computer
suggestions but
they're not really helping the black
side at all
what is tried is Bishop a5 in the game
and what follows is Queen a6 applying
pressure to the rook Bishop takes c7 and
after Queen c4 how to cope with this pin
Black has worked themselves into a self
pin and there's not a successful way to
untangle what is tried is a five Bishop
takes e5 rook takes black gives the
exchange trying to grab some activity
trying to maybe get into this a five
square for something along this diagonal
but the movie six this pin again remains
be six is in there is no Queen e5 King
f8 is tried rook c1 piling up on this
pinned piece and that's it
there's nothing to do Carlson resigns at
this point and he was way down on time
as well having to invest a ton of time
early on with that Knight d2 f6 move
again that follow-up move when there was
the capture on e4 D takes e4 would have
been a better try I believe but in this
one we have now a level match and a big
big deal this game is without question
to level the match at this point again
after rook a c1 Carlson resigned this
pushes it to even score one and a half
points to one and a half points and this
is anons first victory over Carlsen in a
long while
certainly in world chess championship
play it was Carlsen winning three games
and the rest draws in the 2013 matchup
but I guess we can say with this one the
tiger strikes back and things are level
things are without question heating up I
was very excited covering this live I
will again continue to do live streams
and the videos as well and I hope you
follow along
this is very exciting stuff feel free to
share what your comments thoughts are on
this and I'll catch you in the next
video and as always I hope you got
something out of it take care bye
you